three
two
[Music]
thus begins my quest to build the
perfect marshmallow launching machine
this is a catapult model it would be
extremely dangerous if you were
this tall or like a angry squirrel
and this model is inspired by the
drawings of
this genius leonardo da vinci
the same guy who painted the super
famous mona lisa
it's overrated but still pretty good
a catapult launches something in the air
using power from
tension or gravity instead of using
gunpowder
there are different types this one's
called a man janelle
it's what you usually think of there's
also a ballista
think of a crossbow and a trebuchet this
part is super heavy
in the cow i mean the
stone you sorrow goes here then the
stone gets released
and the heavy stuff helps shoot the
stone up and out
like a big slingshot catapults were
invented
in china and europe around the 4th
century bc and
it was actually a breakthrough they
could launch
big heavy stones at walls and enemies
you could break through a wall with it
did i mention we have cicadas here can
you hear the cicadas
[Music]
in the 1300s people said catapults were
even used to launch
dead bodies over walls because people
wanted to spread the plague
to their enemies on the corpses but
leonardo's catapult
it was as elegant as one of his
paintings
now the first thing is to assemble the
drum let's go ahead and do that
today leonardo has a reputation for
inventing things
but when we look back a lot of his
inventions were just improvements
on things that already existed like this
drawing of a ladder to scale castle
walls
he even made a few things that just
didn't work
this helicopter looks awesome but it
probably wouldn't fly
his catapults weren't some totally new
thing he took tried and true
elements from other catapults and made
the design his own
our catapult is actually a mashup of
these two drawings leonardo made
let's switch to something that makes it
easier to see what leonardo was thinking
that's better okay so the drum and
ratchet
are going to be how we wind up the
catapult they're kind of like the
charger to the battery that gives us all
the power
for this one you turned the handle here
to wind up the drop
that winds up and pulls the rope which
pulls back the wood pieces
here now they hold a lot of energy that
you use
winding up the drum and that is pretty
much how this catapult works too
see how when i wind the catapult the
drum turns
and pulls back these rods all that
tension
lets it launch a payload in our case
it's a marshmallow in leonardo's it
would have been a large
stone or some other projectile that
could just bash into
castle walls in leonardo's you probably
whacked
this thing here with a hammer to set the
gear loose
and fire in ours you lock it by hooking
this bar right here to this gear
it stops it in place that's taken from
leonardo's second design
you wound the gear by sticking a bar in
one of these holes
and pulling everything more taut over
and over again
then see the bar that locks to a gear it
holds the gear
in place that is what ours does too when
we
pull the release rope the bar comes
loose the drum unwinds
and the catapult fires it's pretty easy
a good catapult can hold that tension
for as long as it has to
it requires all those elements to work
in tandem and the person firing it to
have the right touch
which i do if one thing goes wrong
like right here where the bar is out of
place the energy is lost
and after a few tries i believe that i
will be able to make this catapult do
something amazing
to fire the perfect marshmallow
this is a crossbow leonardo designed see
that dude there
that's how big this thing was and here's
leonardo's trebuchet
and his ideas for sweet shields to
protect soldiers
he was a genius he drew a baby in the
womb and imagined a parachute and made a
crazy
accurate overhead map but he was also a
guy
doodling in a bunch of different
notebooks his catapult was probably
never used in war
but his designs mashed together some
really clever ideas
people are still tinkering with the
design of catapults
this is being launched off a carrier by
a kind of catapult
and from looking at them we can still be
inspired to create a replica and i'm no
leonardo but that's something that
we can do too we can adapt stuff i'm
going to attach this to the ground and
make the release rope
a little longer so that i can launch it
myself and
get that sweet marshmallow arcing in the
air that is something that we can all do
we can't all draw or instantly
understand physics
or get people to build weapons but we
can all
imagine something amazing three
two one
[Music]
so
[Music]
ugh
you're 22 years old get it together
three two one